what's something I wouldn't believe
about you oh something that you probably
wouldn't believe about me and many
people always are shocked when I tell
them because I'm such a
happy outgoing person is I'm actually a
felon
um committed a felony many years back I
regret it did my time and uh now I just
look forward to being a more positive
and doing more positive in this world
uh something you wouldn't believe about
me is that when I was a kid I
started two forest fires and I learned a
lot from that and I've devoted my life
to uh
helping the environment and I've devoted
all my studies to environmental
sustainability and trying to rectify
those wrongs that I did as a child
I think
what you want to believe about me is
that I am I just got a job as an
advocate working with victims for crime
and basically that entails like making
sure that there's like Services provided
for them like if there's like a need for
clothing or like shelter or food and
that kind of stuff and it's funny
because
I just got that job however I am using
the same Services because I can't afford
clothes professional clothes that I'm
required to wear and
[Music]
um
it's just very it's just interesting
um to be like supposedly in this
position of like you know Authority
that's helping other people and yet I
still can't even like get my own needs
met
this woman asked me last night because
uh it was my last day at my job but she
asked me she's like so so like you want
to save people and I was like no I was
like no I don't wanna I do not want to
save people I'm not trying to save
people I want people to save themselves
like I want people to be empowered and
to like realize their full potential and
know that like coming from like really
stuff can still make it you know like
um I just want to be an example you know
for people to like see their worth and
their like
yeah their uniqueness and like their
resilience
yeah people look at me and think that
I'm naive but I've been through a lot
and I noticed patterns that people
wouldn't think I would think
I don't know I I tend to space out a lot
and people take I've heard from friends
that people take deer and headlights as
naive but it just means that I'm
thinking a lot and my creativity is way
out there
you could read people pretty well
because of what exactly very much so
okay unless some a girl is flirting with
me and then I'm just it just goes over
my head
um that I played uh football for eight
years I wrestled for two years I played
tennis for a year baseball soccer I've
done every sport you could possibly
imagine
why do you think people might be shocked
to hear that
um I'm very flamboyant I think that's
number one I could be a professional
Long Snapper honestly if I if I went
back into it you don't know what a Long
Snapper is I know no one does so we
special teams are never on the field at
all and then I go out and I'm the center
and I snap the ball 15 yards back so I
just like Snap and be like oh
you're so good at it that you think you
think I could have but I just didn't
like anybody on the team I didn't like
any
boys on the team why do you why'd you
play I had three older brothers
just followed Sue it's just easier as
you can tell
um just easier to blend in than stand
out
I am
not American
because everyone says I'm a California
boy SoCal core so people don't realize
I'm only lived here like three years
where are you from Norway did you fit in
not really I lived in a tiny village and
the only uh I was the only guy my hair
used to be all the way down to my back
so everyone thought I was a girl and I
was Outcast and I moved here and I fit
right in no I just copied people accents
and I get here
it's that easy
they have a 32 year old son and five
children
I'm 48 years old and I have a 32 year
old a 26 year old a 24 year old a 15
year old an eight-year-old having a
child at 15 that it has been challenging
but I'm able to grow up with my son so
we are best friends we were yes like he
would say that you're his best friend
yes he would say I'm his best friend yes
called me all the time and actually
random crap that I really don't want to
answer
about women that I'm like no son that's
not for Mommy
and now he has six six I have six
grandkids because of him so life is good
um I've cleaned 3 000 fish tanks in a
single year it's pretty it's kind of a
fluke um I I was bouncing around between
jobs and then I got my girlfriend at the
time a tiny little betta fish and then I
spent every day at the fish store by my
house and then eventually he told me
just to start working there and so I did
and then after a few years of doing that
um I started cleaning fish tanks for him
and then realized that I just really
like cleaning fish tanks I just like
giving fish good habitats and stuff
makes me happy and then eventually I
moved away and started my own business
yeah it's pretty good business it's
Bob's Fish services
wait I'm curious why you like the queen
Queen oh I think fish are such an
underappreciated pet and they don't
really get the clean tanks that they
deserve and I'm kind of a perfectionist
but more along the lines of I just want
every fish to have the best home that
they can
um terribly afraid of insects spiders
millipedes centipedes
dillapedes all of the above there's like
a giant picture of one on a van down
there
and I can look at that I told her I had
to cover it up you know what I'm saying
I have to go like this
I couldn't even do it I had to go like
this so
just think about it just thinking about
us crazy yeah I don't like them uh
something that you wouldn't believe
about me is that I'm from Backwoods
Wisconsin and I'm also a United States
Marine Corps veteran I don't look very
like fresh out of the military and I've
got the dietary and piercings and face
tattoos and hand tattoos and that's not
something that you see common in the
military so
um so I went to school for EMT so I
could be a firefighter but I broke my
leg really bad so I never actually went
into the field but I've actually saved
several lives outside of doing that
anyway some people choking some people
drowning some people heart attacks and
well three for sure
one I don't know if he ever totally
recovered one was had a heart attack at
Home Depot one got sucked under a log
Jam and a river and when I found her
under there she was gray and her colored
all changed and the other person was
choking the point where they you know
couldn't get any air at all and
what feeling does that leave you with
nothing special really honestly ever
just one of those people who will act
and so it just comes kind of normal uh
something you wouldn't believe about me
I speak seven languages
so Italian my first language
German French English Spanish Japanese
and some Portuguese
about six years ago I weighed 300 pounds
and now I'm down to 150. I think I was
like 20 25 26 and I couldn't walk up a
flight of stairs like I was out of
breath my feet hurt my legs hurt I was
in pain and
I was like why why I mean this is so bad
it's been a really long long journey but
I probably would have not been here if
you know I didn't make the decision
because I was very very depressed and
very unhealthy
wouldn't believe yeah
uh you wouldn't believe that I'm a
person
who have a maybe three immigration and
was born in a in Russian Ural and my
parents brought me to Ukraine and all my
life I spent in Ukraine and then was
from Soviet Union we immigrate to Israel
so I have Israel passport then we
immigrate to Canada I have Canadian
passport and I I lived a lot of in
Europe and I
have German and now soon I will be
American so my collector collector of
the passport and experience and I feel
like I'm a person of the world and I
accept any nationality my boyfriend now
originally his parents from China
and before I had
um Ukrainian husband then I had German
husbands
and maybe it will be wife of the Chinese
American this is you cannot believe
thank you
hi everyone thank you for watching I'll
be posting bonus footage from this
episode on my patreon that means more
answers and extended cuts of each answer
if you want to see it you can sign up
I'll have it linked in my description
and if I ever do follow-ups on the
people you see in this episode that'll
be on my patreon as well thank you guys
for watching I love you all and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
foreign